There's a really weird story
I wanted to share with you coming out of Germany.
(fast rock music)
A politician from Hamburg Germany.
I'm sorry where is that music coming from?
Do you hear that music Andy?
Yeah a little bit I guess,
I mean it's not that loud.
(audience laughing)
Andy it is loud,
what's going on with your lectern,
what is that?
Oh oh this, okay well listen
you know how my cousin was arrested by park rangers
for doing that really
creepy thing in Griffith Park?
No.
Well my family's collecting bail money to get
my cousin out of jail and to replace the RV
that he damaged and to buy that little girl a new pony.
So I thought I'd make some extra money
by getting a sponsor for my lectern.
(fast rock music)
Tonight's lectern is sponsored
by Gold Winner 10-in-1 sport gel for men.
Andy I didn't approve any of this.
Well yeah that's why I didn't ask you.
(audience laughing)
Is it okay if I show the add for the body gel?
No Andy it's not okay.
Thanks Conan roll it Billy.
[Billy] Real guys don't buy
10 bottles when they can buy just one.
Introducing Gold Winner 10-in-1 Sports Gel for men.
A shampoo, conditioner and body soap
all in one.
It's also a toothpaste, a tile grout
and eye drops plus it's an engine additive,
a sex lubricant and a life saving
heart reviving adrenaline injection.
And the best sports
drink you've ever had.
10-in-1!
[Billy] 10-in-1!
(audience laughing)
(audience applauding)
So well what do you think?
That is awful.
That's terrible and now you're stuck
with that stupid lectern.
Oh no I'm not because 10-in-1
Sports Gel is also very flammable.
(audience applauding)
See!
(audience cheering)
[Conan] We'll take a break.